مرحبا بك منذ قليل لشهاده مدينه القامشلي
هزه ارضيه اهتزت المباني كما تلاحظين في
هذه الصور المباشره معظم الاهالي خرجوا
الى شوارع وغادروا شققهم السكنيه بصحبه
الاطفال البعض استقلوا السيارات وخرجوا من
من المدينه لشده الهزه الارضيه هناك حاله
هلا عامه في شوارع المدينه كما تلاحظين
بعض السيارات بصحبه
العوائل بدات بمغادره وسط المدينه خاصه في
المناطق
المنتزه بالسكان حاله الحلع مستمره في
المدينه طبعا هذه الهزه الثانيه القويه
التي تشهدها مدينه القامشلي العاصمه
الاداريه لمناطق شمال شرق سوريا منذ صباح
اليوم المدينه كانت قد شهدت هزه اخرى في
الساعه 20 دقيقه بتوقيت المحلي
لسوريا كما تلاحظون يعني الان اصبحت مليئه
بالسكان وهناك يعني نزول من شقق السكنيه
وافراغها تحسبا مثلا انهيار المباني طيب
الجمعه يعني اليس هناك اي خطر على الناس
في الشوارع يعني الا يمكن ان تسقط عليهم
المباني وانقاض المباني
المساحات السكنيه هنا ضيقه بعض العوائل
يعني ذهبوا خرجوا من المدينه عبر سياراتهم
لكن الباقي لربما لم يحسموا حتى الان
قرارهم بمغادره المدينه لان المركز
الزلزال يعني ما اعتقده الناس مركز
الزلزال بعيد وهذه هزات
ارتداديه
للزلزال هل كان هناك اي اضرار من هذه
الهزه الارتداديه هل هل تكسرت شبابيك
المباني هل هناك اي نوع من انواع الاضرار
حتى وان كانت طفيفه اهتزت المباني اهتزت
اهتزت المباني بشكل
قوي هذا الامر اثار رعب وهل لدى الاهالي
الذين قاموا بانزال الاطفال ونزلوا الى
الى شوارع العامه لكن حتى الان لا توجد
ايه اضرار